an insanity plea for Charleston shooter
Dylann roof will be a hard sell we now
know that he's a documented white
supremacist inspired by an organization
whose rhetoric is becoming more and more
mainstream in a manifesto allegedly
written by roof that's now under
investigation by the FBI he says he
chose to attack the Charleston community
for its black history he also says that
he first became quote racially aware
during George Zimmerman's trial over the
killing of Trayvon Martin and was led to
the website of the Council of
conservative citizens it's a group with
roots in Pro segregation movements of
the 1950s and 60s and it's a cries
racial diversity while it doesn't
support swastikas or pointy hats like
other more recognizable hate groups it
does trot out the Confederate flag and
hateful language the co-founder once
called black people a retrograde species
of humanity their newsletter often rails
against black on white crime and
believes in an endangered white race but
the CCC has distanced itself from the
Charleston massacre saying it
unequivocally condemns roofs murderous
actions but it does call the shooters
viewpoints legitimate grievances and
says that not addressing those issues is
dangerous which sounds more like a
warning than a condemnation and even
though its membership peak of 15,000 was
in the 1990s the ccc still has its hands
in politics
former Arkansas governor and
presidential candidate Mike Huckabee
spoke at a ccc national convention in
the 90s and the group's current leader
has donated money to mit romney Ted Cruz
Rick Santorum Scott Walker and Rand Paul
guys that want to be our president
now some campaigns are falling over
themselves to return that money dozens
of other officials across the country
have ties to the CCC as well including
former Mississippi Governor Haley
Barbour and at one point a third of its
state legislators what worries many is
that the CCC's rhetoric is becoming
increasingly mainstream especially when
it comes to immigration as
anti-immigrant speech has made its way
into the tea party and other far-right
arenas when Mexico sends its people
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime they're rapists it's an invasion
it's absolutely an invasion of our
country they weigh a hundred and thirty
pounds and they've got calves the size
of cantaloupes because they're all in 75
pounds of marijuana across the desert
but the CCC isn't alone there are more
than 500 white supremacist groups across
the u.s. since 2000 membership in these
groups has exploded especially since the
election of the first black president
many of the most recent mass shootings
in the US have been fueled by racism and
committed by white supremacists like the
killing of Sikh worshippers at a temple
in Wisconsin the murder of three people
in a Jewish Center in Kansas City and
now the shooting of nine black
worshippers in Charleston how can this
country move on from its racist past
when so many of its leaders won't okay
just to give you a flavor of the
different type of Confederate gear they
have here in the store this is a flag
for $5.00 this is a cutting board about
$17 this right here a hundred percent
Egyptian cotton sheets